[Music]
foreign
to give a workshop within little called
from our user to our programmer
my name is Emma Rand and I'm an
associate for offering conversational
biology at the University of York in the
UK these are my three reasons for taking
our Workshop
so number one
we think this is for any our user so
whether you've been using R for a while
or you're relatively new if you want to
take that step from user to programmer
then our Workshop might be for you
number two we want to make you more
efficient so you can do less copying and
pasting of Code by teaching you two
techniques one is how to write functions
that follow conventions which make them
easier to write and to use
and secondly we're going to teach you
iteration which shows you how to do the
same the same action on lots of
different R objects
and then number three I think is me and
Ian so we can both remember what it was
like to learn some of these techniques
and the sort of light bulb moments it
gave us and we really feel quite
passionately that it would be great to
give other people that experience of
really making the leap into our
programmer so I hope to see you there in
autumn
I'm Ian little a data scientist at
Schneider Electric
and I am so excited to be working with
amaran on a one day workshop at
positconf called from our user to our
programmer
if you've written some art scripts some
of our markdown reports maybe even some
quarter reports and you're looking to
put a little more power into your R code
this Workshop could be for you
we're going to talk about how you can
write your own functions
show ways to avoid trouble
for example functions can have side
effects
let me show you what I mean
this is Benford he's a wonderful Basset
Hound
Binford created this side effect
by chewing up this boot
now side effects aren't necessarily bad
things and they usually aren't
but there's something that we should
keep our eye on
we'll show you how you can use the with
our package to manage side effects
let's say you've written a function to
read a specially formatted file but you
have a directory full of these files
we'll show you how you can use the per
package to run this function many times
instead of just once
I think you'll enjoy working with Emma
and me
Emma made this point in her video so I
hope she won't mind that I use it too
we've both been there we both know how
frustrating it can be to get something
working
and how awesome it feels when everything
falls into place
the whole point of our Workshop is to
make it easier for you to get to awesome
Chicago is one of my favorite places and
it's amazing in September
Emma and I both hope you can join us all
in Chicago for positkov 2023